it is seven o'clock you're watching a
Sky News special the BBC in crisis a q a
when will the revelations end says
tonight a second young person makes
allegations against the unnamed BBC
presenter
we'll ask the questions the BBC's
director General needs to answer as it's
reveals that the presenter wasn't spoken
to until seven weeks after the complaint
was made
tonight I'll be joined by guests who've
been at the sharp end at the corporation
and Beyond
we'll also ask if the Sun newspaper
needs to answer some questions to a rich
treatment of the story after the young
person at the center of the allegations
allegedly rubbishes its claims
plus we'll ask whether anything can
really ever remain Secret in today's
social media landscape and look at the
potential consequences for the famous
and those online
[Music]
good evening you're watching a Sky News
special program on the crisis at the BBC
now it's four days since we learned that
an unnamed BBC presenter has been
accused of paying for explicit images
from a young person starting when that
person was 17. now tonight it's being
reported that a second individual says
that they felt threatened by the unnamed
presenter and were sent abusive
expletive filled messages after hinting
they can name them online now in a
moment I'll be putting questions to our
panel of experts but first Sky's home
Affairs editor Jason Farrell is here
with us and Jason this story just keeps
evolving tell us the latest as we
understand it just gone seven yeah it
feels like we've had a week of
developments in the last 24 hours only
24 hours ago we were talking about the
young person saying that this
development was rubbish then we had the
Sun newspaper with the parents coming
out and saying that everything they'd
said was true and actually the BBC was
lying then this morning we've had the
BBC layout its timeline of events I
think that is significant so for the
first time we've seen the BBC say
exactly how this complaint came in how
they responded I.E that they sent an
email getting clarification that they
didn't get a response to then they said
they made a phone call about three weeks
later which they didn't get a response
to then they left it a month and then
the sun came out with its story and only
then did they speak to the presenter
only then were senior Executives and the
director General aware of this story so
there's all sorts of questions then came
out about the BBC's handling we saw the
director General being interviewed on
the world at one where the presenter
said everyone in this building knows who
it is
there was just been extraordinary
development he his his defense for not
naming the individual is around uh
privacy around duty of Care by the BBC
but then the BBC's own reporters then
come out with a story at four o'clock
this afternoon saying there's another
allegation this time the presenter has
been into a dating chat room has
arranged to meet up in a more private
chat room and has revealed himself to
someone wanted to meet up didn't happen
and then when the person says that they
might reveal who the presenter is the
presenter has become threatening we've
talked about menacing messages we
haven't seen them but menacing in nature
so again the story opens up in a in a
different way who knows where it will go
next absolutely and Jason thank you for
that before I introduce our panel of
experts here to talk us through what the
BBC is facing in the last few moments
one of the BBC's main presenters Jeremy
Vine has tweeted now he of course was
harassed on social media with people
thinking that he was the person at the
center of this but Jeremy Vine has
tweeted in the past half an hour or so
saying I'm starting to think that the
BBC presenter involved in the Scandal
should now come forward publicly these
new allegations will result in yet more
virtual being thrown at perfectly
innocent colleagues of his and the BBC
which I'm sure he loves is on its knees
with this but it is his decision and his
alone so pressure they're being piled on
now we're going to start by asking the
one question that we can't actually
answer for you who is the person at the
center of this and we're going to get
Jason to explain why doesn't Sky News
aren't naming the person that is alleged
to be at the center of it no I'm not
going to answer that question
um and there's a there's a number of
reasons why I and other journalists are
not answering that question uh and the
the key one is really privacy laws and
Supreme Court actually came out with a
new ruling on this only last year which
which essentially protects an individual
even when they're under investigation so
only after they get charged is there a
necessity to to name them now obviously
for newspaper thinks it's got slam dunk
absolutely solid information that crime
has been committed they might then say
we're going to name them anyway
um but that's not necessarily the case
here with the Sun and in fact the sense
from their statement is that they feel
that the BBC has acted inappropriately
in the face of the allegations some some
of which they say they've seen
supporting evidence of but perhaps not
enough to come out with the name
themselves and certainly if they haven't
we haven't seen the evidence they've got
other media Outlets aren't going to and
then of course on top of that there's
the defamation laws where if if someone
says libless about something some
something liabilous about an individual
they could of course Sue okay Jason
thank you for that now with us to pick
through many of the questions that we
have this evening are Lauren beaching
the founder of Crisis management energy
honest London Persephone Bridgeman Baker
media lawyer and partner at Carter rack
and archil Ahmed professor of media at
the University of Bolton and a former
head of Religion and Ethics at the BBC
and at Channel 4. guys thank you so much
for being with us this evening plenty to
get to let's start with you Persephone
and these latest allegations if we can
because of course we must remember that
nothing illegal has been alleged yet
entirely we're not certain exactly when
this began so do these latest
allegations change anything do you think
materially about the situation we're
facing I don't think they change
aerially obviously the more allegations
that mount up the more pressure there is
going to be on this individual to either
step out and name themselves or on the
BBC to consider naming them but as Jason
brightly says this individual still has
the protection of anonymity
um which is pretty much settled law in
this country now that means he can't be
named and these these further
allegations don't go to for example
um or don't appear to go to abuse as a
possession within his profession or any
further allegations of criminality so I
don't think that the new allegations
change their position dramatically and
Akil would you agree with that and let's
also remember as well what we've just
reported uh Jeremy Ryan coming out and
saying that this person should perhaps
name themselves well I think that's easy
for Jeremy to say isn't it really I mean
I can understand where he's coming from
for himself from his own position but
actually you know it's not for him to
tell somebody what to do we don't know
the circumstances for the other
individual involved we don't we
generally it's all unfolding as we go
along and to answer the the first bit of
the question well it it changes
something not necessarily the nature of
of what of any because if you don't know
about any illegality obviously but it
does change something which is
this is somebody coming forward now
because this story is out there and we
now know we don't know who else will
come forward and we don't know what what
else we will learn from this so in that
sense the lack of control as it were
that anybody seems to have over the
story is resulting in this you know
we've because of the actual because the
emails have been reported about now
should we've not seen them but the BBC
have actually I think I believe BBC have
seen haven't they and they said that
actually they are of particular menacing
nature so therefore we know it's real so
therefore there will be more that comes
out so that's what I would say it has
changed not necessarily any illegality
but what has changed as the story is
getting wider and now we and now nobody
is in control perhaps more complicated
as well Lauren it's a reputation
management perspective of course you
knew that's a question you're going to
ask you talk to us about
um the individual at the center of this
how you would be advising them and the
BBC yeah I mean from the individual now
with the second person coming forward
without a doubt I would be saying you
need to just come clean
um that would be my personal advice
um I think that's the only way he the
person being accused right now can take
control of the narrative
um
I think he's going to be named
imminently I just feel like it's going
to come out eventually so I feel take
control of the situation and produce an
incredibly strong statement
um very compelling if there's any way he
can prove any slight innocence in this
if there's any evidence he has put it
out there and just be a belly coming to
your other colleagues that are like
Jerry Vine Corelli said they've been
scrutinized and it's just not fair on
them that's what I'm not a certainly
what do you think about as sort of as a
strategy yeah it's difficult to I mean
different clients want to take different
approaches in these situations but
there's certainly something to be said
for getting ahead of the the media
controlling the narrative and trying to
get something out there that might put
your position out there a bit more
neatly and coherently because at the
moment the only person not speaking in
all of this is the person that's been
accused and Jason you know
um what's your take on this I mean the
pressure is being piled on isn't it by
uh Jeremy by saying this and I guess
Jeremy Vine's tweeting he wasn't the
only person over the weekend that was
being harassed on social media it could
be others that come out and say the same
thing yeah I mean I'm no doubt that
there's
um some thought within the BBC that now
they would rather like this individual
to come out and say whatever it is they
need to say
um and it you know it's obviously it's a
personal decision for that particular
individual uh but I think that I think
the the big problem is that is that
point that was made by the BBC presenter
essentially saying look everybody in
this building knows and if everybody in
the BBC knows literally everybody
you know the public the public will
start to learn um if they haven't
already who it is so it almost becomes a
pointless question in a way so then you
would say well I'm not I don't do the
roles you do but you then you would say
well look if everybody knows then that
would seem like the sensible thing to do
well
Well normally I would say you're right
actually because that's what I do as
well so you get control get on top of
the situation control it be on the front
foot rather than reacting but the story
is unfolding the police are not using
the word investigate
um we there doesn't seem to be any
evidence of any illegality at the moment
so you could argue that you may be able
to ride this out a little bit longer and
actually be in more control of the
situation once it starts to calm down if
the stories stop stop developing so
there is another sign to this but I
think ultimately it all boils down to
the same thing you've got to be in
control so they must have a a q a or a
plan as it were a strategy for how they
will deal with this and all the various
different permutations yeah and we'll
address how the BBC should perhaps deal
with it shortly guys thank you for that
well let's just look at what the BBC
have been telling us as this Scandal has
unfolded now the broadcaster has said it
didn't put the allegations made by the
family of the young person to the
accused presenter until seven weeks
after they were first raised the
director General Tim Davey had this to
say when he was asked why it taken so
long for the presenter to be confronted
if you've got an allegation coming into
a corporate investigations team
and I think you need to balance the
concerns of Duty of care privacy all
those things I've talked about
I don't think you take that complaint
direct to a presenter if you just work
that through if anything that comes
through or any call that hasn't been
verified just gets bought in front of
someone what I would say is it is
important at that point I think this is
right to validate that to have our not
just the audit Services team but the
Specialists talk to that individual
understand their concerns and go through
that process I think that's essential
Davey speaking earlier to the world that
one being asked questions by Sarah
Montague now the BBC have revealed a
timeline about the complaint made
against the presenter on the 18th of May
a family member of the young adult at
the center of all of this went to a BBC
building to make the complaint a day
later they contacted BBC audience
Services who escalated it now it was
assessed as not criminal but requiring
further investigation the BBC emailed
the complainant the same day asking for
more information but got no response
three weeks later the BBC made a phone
call to the complainant which did not
connect a month later the son informed
the BBC about the story including new
allegations now this was the first time
that the director general or other
Executives became aware of the case
a senior BBC manager held the first
conversation with the presenter in
question about the allegations later
that same day and they agreed the
presenter would be taken off there the
next day the BBC contacted the police
and on Monday the BBC met with the
police who asked to be to pause their
investigation or officers assess the
case
all right so here's that question I said
we were going to be answering or trying
to at least how has the BBC handled this
Scandal um Lauren what do you think
some better
so it's pretty lightly
um I feel how what would have been a
better way of them dealing with that so
I think the main issue comes down to
what their inner workings of how they're
dealing with complaints so I feel seven
weeks I mean it's inexcusable really
um I feel if they even nipped it but in
the bud straight away as soon as they
received it spoken to the correct people
raised it with Senior Management I don't
know how the writings of their work but
I feel that would generally be how it
would work they would see something
labeled red raise it
um and I feel then that would have
stopped this whole media scrutiny it
would have stopped this crisis happening
it would have stopped innocent people
having Targets on their back and also
the victim as well like it's just caused
uproar for absolutely no reason and I
just feel it's something that they just
need to fix within I think their
argument was though that they get so
many kind of complaints on a daily basis
that they have to kind of be a bit
judicious about which ones they raise up
to to people you don't buy that yeah I
really do and I think this is really
tricky for BBC and what makes it most
tricky is that we you know we don't know
what these allegations are we don't know
how serious they were we don't know the
context in which they were made we don't
know how they were imparted there was a
lot of women looked on the door of a
building yeah in a city we don't know
yeah yeah it's quite unusual and as you
say the BBC may receive many of these
allegations and some of them may be ones
that they have to take through the
proper channels and some of them may not
be and because we just don't know yet
the BBC's come heavily Under Fire for
the way that they've dealt with this and
I just don't think we have enough
information at the moment of course
these allegations as we heard from Jason
you know around 24 hours later in the
public eye we're refuted by the very
victim himself so you know goodness me
it's just a really chaotic situation for
the BBC and Knuckles the the former BBC
man on the panel you'll know a little
bit about the inner workings well I
think Tim talked earlier on about 250
complaint in a serious complaint it's
not just complaints but serious
complaints in a six-month period I mean
and they did this so this was an
investigation that was opened an email
was sent no one replied to it then you
you know there's not one person looking
after this they probably there's a
person looking after about probably
about 50 or 20 or 40 cases so you so the
investigation was ongoing and it is and
but obviously it's escalated I mean you
could have it was never closed it was
never closed yet no we can have an
argument about whether or not that seven
weeks was was too long but the fact of
the matter is it was there was an
investigation going on and this would
have been dealt with as it has been
dealt with I mean I guess question
somebody asks whether they should have
sent more emails or maybe tried to make
more phone calls because one of each is
probably not quite enough let's bring in
uh David Elston now former chief
executive of channel five and also a
former BBC producer there he is over
that side David good to have you with us
as a shame you're not in the studio
we've got plenty of people here but uh
nice to have you in the screen anyway
it's very crowded
uh listen pick up on this point then how
do you think the BBC is handled uh this
scandal
well I I'm sorry to say this special uh
dividers BBC in crisis because you have
to ask yourself what's the BBC done
wrong uh one of its employees uh uh one
of its high profile presenters is
alleged to have done something uh was it
criminal in that case it's a matter for
the police
uh if it's not criminal
um what is it that requires and I
frankly had no idea that BBC had uh an
investigations unit it sounds really
orwellian uh I would have been shocked
when I was working BBC to hear that
there was an in-house investigations
unit
um the thing is that people's private
lives are private lives people can do
uh unwise things as Phillips Schofield
might put it
um even things that might shock uh
someone they might have affairs they
might uh try to approach people 30 years
younger themselves all of these might
happen but why is the BBC investigating
them unless there's something that is
going to bring the BBC into disrepute
and therefore might involve a breach of
contract so I I think that the way the
whole issue has been put is really
unfortunate for the BBC and the BBC has
made itself uh a target for everyone to
Pile in on every politician who's ever
stood in an election in East Berwick or
west Lothian it feels free to have a go
at the BBC through an investigation do
one faster and then the police say no
stop your investigation unless I'm a Tim
David I'd be very nervous of being uh
held responsible for impeding the police
investigation so frankly uh I find
the whole situation not just orwellian
but rather as well it's so grotesque I
mean the the Guardians media editor
today asks Tim Davey have you examined
the presenter's phone
I mean what world does the guardian live
in the Stasi
why would Tim Davey David want to accept
absolutely
get bringing our other guests as well
David and I want to do want to put a
point to you because the the reason I
guess that it has been elevated to this
level is because the allegation is that
the person at the time that first
Contact was made was 17 and there may
well have been the soliciting of
pictures of a person under the age which
is why now now that said of course it
hasn't gone it has it hasn't gone to the
police in terms of that yet but that I
think is why it's been raised up to this
level
I I understand that but it the first
thing you say to the complainant is is
there a criminal act if so please report
it to your local police station it's the
BBC is not
a law enforcement agency the only thing
that the BBC needs to look after is
whether one of its employees is going to
bring it into disrepute uh by doing
something which is potentially a breach
of contract but
it's not the BBC that we should be
talking about as being in crisis it's
the media for turning this into a
free-for-all with poor old Tim Davey yet
again the punch bag that Everyone likes
to have a go at it's
they I think they behave foolishly in
not passing it off to the police
straight away okay I'm saying David over
to you appreciate that specifically pick
up on some I don't know where you want
to start with so we we have heard
recently that it was referred to the
police as well and they initially
decided not to investigate because they
weren't they weren't sure that those
were criminal um allegations I do think
I have some sympathy there with the you
know you need to make sure that you're
investigating and the the right sort of
circumstances it
it's simply again that we're back to we
don't know what to allege but but you
know it is important that the BBC makes
sure that its presenters aren't bringing
um the the BBC into disrepute there are
public service broadcaster one might say
that adds additional obligations onto
them and um and so I think in those
situations one would want to make sure
that once employees were behaving in a
professional and proper manner but pick
up on that private life things rather
David mentioned there I mean sort of how
bad in your private life can you be to
keep your job at the BBC do you know
well this I mean some of these
allegations the dating Rome allegations
you know are truly private allegations
but we shouldn't have any impact on the
person they shouldn't but if they are
then aired that is likely to bring or
possibly could bring the BBC into
dystrophy so we are really traveling a
very fine line here between what's in
the public interest and what someone's
doing in their their private life yeah
let's just bring sort of the other part
in this another party which is the Sun
newspaper of course which publishes the
obligations to start with now they first
brought this story to the Public's
attention but the individual that send
to all the allegations has told the BBC
through their lawyer that nothing
inappropriate took place with the
unnamed presenter the son however says
the parents of the young person involved
stand by their comments now does the Sun
have questions to answer you're having a
drink so I'll start with you what do you
think
um well well we don't know if they have
questions to answer again okay
journalistically journalism 101 right if
you don't have the facts you don't you
don't publish which is what we'll go on
to that I'm sure when we talk about
Twitter now with regards to the with the
Sun newspaper I just want to know
they've got all this information why
have we not seen any of it do you think
they should be publishing you well I
mean I I'm quite surprised that actually
if they have the um the bank statements
Etc why are we not seeing redacted
versions of those bank statements if
they have imagery Etc why are we not
seeing redacted versions of the image
all of this stuff is actually it doesn't
seem like they would normal behavior
from a tabloid newspaper plus also just
the last Point
um that thing when when they got when
the when the person involved alleged you
know got in touch with the newspaper
they doubled down a little bit and said
it's up to the BBC to do a proper
investigation which would suggest they
might not have done a proper
investigation themselves yeah long
before I'm starting before I bring you
in let me get David's point is the other
journal on the panel Dave what do you
think of that should the uh should the
Sun have answer a few questions and as
uh article said publish their evidence
well uh but some uh will in due course
come under quite severe scrutiny uh
because
why haven't they been quizzing the
mother and the stepfather
um with some questions like how do you
know it's 35 000 pounds when did you
note was 35 000 pounds how long have you
known that something you don't approve
of has been going on why have you waited
now and if your son or stepson denies
that anything improper has happened what
makes you so certain that something has
where is your evidence so uh the mother
and stepfather are being shielded by the
sun because the son is choosing to
believe them over the young person
involved so the time will come when the
spotlight will switch from the BBC
perhaps to the sun perhaps the parents
um but it's not quite there yet we can
we can keep talking about it David
because as you know you know the Sun as
an entity into and sometimes a bit of a
law into itself so they they have no
obligation to publish this evidence do
they and they can keep um churning out
new lines from this story as they see
fit
well once they start accusing the BBC of
being Liars
um they get closer and closer to the
line where uh they that that bite back
happens look the sun's a pretty
impressive newspaper journalistically uh
it it breaks a lot of important stories
and the people who run it uh are
actually used to be the same people who
ran Sky News until Sky News was solved
Comcast so uh there's there's no doubt
in my mind that the decision to publish
this story uh was not taken lightly all
I regret is that the sun had turned it
into an anti-bbc story
the course the presenter question
happens to work for the BBC I mean when
you employ 22 000 people the chances
that you might have someone who's done
something improper or even criminal is
quite High
um and I think the sun should have
targeted the individual
not the BBC but that's
um the way they operate all right David
that still happened in 2018 as well just
for the record all right Persephone just
on the sun I mean Kelvin McKenzie former
Zone editor did say yesterday in the
good old days they would have published
the name and the pictures already I mean
first on the premise of that whatever
but the the good old days there's been a
big shift in Privacy Law since the good
old days
um and you know the Cliff Richard case
against the BBC was eventually settled
for somewhere in the region of two
million pounds in Damages and costs so
it's a significant risk to name somebody
who's associated with a potential
criminal investigation and and as you
know rightly said they will not have
taken the decision to publish this story
lately yeah and that's the thing isn't
it Lauren because they will have made a
decision and they're running with this
story for days as like I said they've
doubled down in some instances so they
must be pretty confident of their
sourcing they seem to be I mean the
speed that they came back out with that
statement last night was astonishing I
wasn't expecting to hear it that fast
but I'm in complete agreement
um I was so confused that no sort of
bank statements blurred out any
information was shared I found that
really bizarre because I wouldn't be
sharing any sort of key information
about that person it would just be a
little bit of evidence which I don't
know just seems incredibly out of
character should I be trying to make the
story run for another few days I mean
maybe I think David's right they've
tried to it's this is this is a story
about the BBC rather than the actual
incident and actually I think the the
the key thing here is actually maybe
it's about regulation as well because
you know we're sat in this room here and
we know the level of Regulation the
level of Hoops we would have to go
through before we could even I mean just
call in the BBC Liars is a big thing you
know but actually it seems like the sun
probably feel they can get away with
some of this because the regulation of
newspapers is nowhere near as thorough
as a regulation of Television radio you
haven't even touched on the fact that
this has come just a couple of days
before the BBC published their annual
reports which of course came out today
we'll touch on that later I'm sure all
right now this uh whole Saga is shorter
featuring tomorrow morning's newspapers
we're going to have our extended press
preview and news review from 10 30 with
tonight's news and tomorrow's headlines
now joining Anna will be the journalist
and broadcaster Jenny cleeman and also
Ali Mirage so stay with us for that
starts at 10 30. now
if you scan the QR code that you see
right now on screen you can listen to
the latest edition of The Sky News Daily
in it Kimberly Leonard will be looking
at the crisis at the BBC you can
subscribe to that podcast wherever you
get your podcasts on a daily basis or
Through the Sky News app
all right plenty more to come this hour
on this Sky News special program looking
at the BBC in crisis next we're going to
examine how this situation may have
changed the entire media landscape
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
everything
foreign
[Music]
welcome back you're watching a Sky News
special on the BBC in crisis now the
claims against the unnamed BBC presenter
prompted friends in speculation over the
presenter's identity on social media
several BBC stars are now spoken at the
distance themselves from the allegations
including Vicky Campbell Gary lineker
and Rylan Clark so with allegations from
a second young person and even more
pressure online can anyone survive a
scandal while maintaining full privacy
over their identity I mean it's kind of
a big question okay let's start with you
I mean
the sort of the pylon over the weekend
was was quite astounding um
and each time this sort of thing happens
we're getting more and more of this
aren't we that people just feel like
they can't throw anything out on social
media and become their own source I
think it says quite a lot about social
media and this and the lack of
Regulation or you know complete lack of
Regulation but actually the fact of the
matter is the laws of the land apply and
a lot of people have are shocked to find
out that actually they're going to get
they could get done for um defamation
and that Nikki who's an old friend of
mine Nikki used to work for me you know
one of my presenters and I asked him if
it was okay because the pylon and you
know for him there was a the people were
actually alleging it was in and he's
passed it on to the police because and I
think he's done the right thing because
people need to stop this you know I mean
in the old days I used to advise people
and I'm I'm victim of this as well they
would say to people don't give it any
Oxygen Let It Die unfortunately in the
digital age in the social media age you
can't do that because it exists forever
and then it goes all around the world
and then some person sat some keyboard
warrior in North America thinks oh this
is all real this thing that's happening
there these fabricated lies and then
they will kind of like spread it and it
just goes on and on and on so what this
has shown is that social media needs to
have some form of control because
otherwise individuals who have no idea
about they have no media literacy when
it comes to this have no idea that
they're breaking the law I mean it's two
points I don't want to pick up on I mean
do the media literacy bit later because
that is a fascinating topic but the law
on it Persephone I mean like if you you
can't just say mad things on the
internet about people you can't prove
you're absolutely right you know
defamation law and the privacy laws that
we have in this country don't just
extend to mainstream Publishers that
extend to every individual making
allegations about another individual
which are false or invade their private
life and that could include something
that you say on Twitter or on any other
social media platform and you know it's
not strictly for the social media
platforms to immediately be policing and
be enforcing that you will still have
your own responsibility as an individual
as well so people need to be very
careful about sharing tweeting
retweeting let's stay with the social
media platforms responsibility I think
as you say you know what things got to
be flagged has got to be reported to
whichever company that's the uh the
platform was uh behind that's a bit of a
slow process isn't it because with
something like this it's escalating and
it's snowballing every hour that it's
not been sort of dealt with it can be
and they do tend to take allegations of
the missus of private information much
more seriously and act upon them much
more quickly than they do about
allegations of defamation where you've
got an allegation of defamation the
question is um is is the allegation true
and social media providers often try to
sort of hide behind the idea that they
don't want to be the officer of Truth
and they'll lead us up to the courts or
for
other determination mechanism but but
they do they do they can take action
quite quickly and I have seen them take
action quite quickly but it doesn't
always happen David what do you think
about the way that social media is
working in this particular instance I
mean back in the day I think a
newspapers wasn't the motto is it true
will they sue
uh
the real problem is anonymity online uh
anyone can hide behind a pseudonym or
some label that isn't there themselves
and it takes forever to find out who it
was who made the full statement so the
risks that are being run of being super
definition of eliminated because uh the
social media Giants are in favor of
allowing anonymity
um I I wish it weren't the case but it
that is the case I think though that uh
there's an interesting little wrinkle
here if the Sun is declining to name the
presenter uh because of fears of uh
breaching privacy laws over someone who
might be uh at some point accused of
criminality what they do when the police
say there's no criminality involved here
because that takes away their uh legal
Shields then
it's time to put up a shutter they're
going to have to name the person uh say
specifically uh what is alleged to have
happened because if it's not criminal
then they should be saying why they
published the story in the first place
so I think when the police have done
their
investigation and tell us that there's
nothing to see here
that's when the story will get really
interesting again we'll see if that's
the way the investigation plays out
won't be David uh Lauren I mean you will
have seen some of the stuff that's going
on on social media it was really quite
extreme and spiritual pick up on this
idea that
people on social media not only did they
not have the sort of the law in their
heads but they also just seem to think
that anything can be said because you're
sitting at your computer or on your
phone it's a free-for-all I mean I can
go from it from a human perspective so
my clients I've dealt with lots of
canceled clients
um and the first thing I generally do
with them is worry about them and tell
most of the time when they reach out to
me they're in a pretty poor state of
mental illness they're panicking it's
the scariest thing and I tell them to
log other socials I log in them and I I
experience what they're actually seeing
and it's deaf threats accusations it's
it starts with one story and it just
spreads it's insane I've never seen
anything like it honestly
um and yeah it's unbelievable I mean
just yesterday and well the day before
all four names were trending on Twitter
and I don't believe I feel that there
should be a way to be able to manage
trending topics on Twitter because that
escalates it so much further but foreign
but there's a new social media platform
that just launched that doesn't have
trending yes right with threads right I
mean I don't I mean that's not the
answer of course but we have said that
I'm speaking purely in a personal
capacity now what uh because of some of
the work that I do is in this area but
if you look at the investment that has
been taken out or the you know the
Twitter particularly in this kind of
area if you've ever made a complaint
about some of the things some of the
things that I said about me I'm a nobody
but some of the things that said about
me real islamophobic racist hatred stuff
um every on the odd occasion that I
thought yeah this is crossed the line
that I've forwarded it on I just get a
reply back literally a minute now this
is this is
there's no point isn't it no and I think
this is the issue here which is if
they're not going to do it themselves
how can we ensure that if we have that I
know we're going to talk it means
literacy how can we ensure that actually
something is done to stop this kind of
thing happening we're going to move on
to some of the legals now number seven
you're going to jump in they're still
first of all privacy
um nor here and how uh this particular
story May well affect the way that
Privacy Law sort of works going forward
as David mentioned this person at the
center of this has the rights to privacy
there's no reason why he has to be named
um but privacy laws changed someone in
recent years hasn't just explained that
to him Privacy Law has developed um over
recent years and it's developed through
the courts and their judicial
interpretation of the law
um there's been no um change in the in
the statute which is what would um you
know what would Governor be interpreted
by the courts but we've seen a number of
cases and there was an injunction just
last week actually
um to prevent the BBC themselves from
publishing information about a criminal
investigation so this is there is more
and more law on on this topic and it's
all going in the same direction
um and the direction being the direct
anonymity anonymity for individuals
during the course of an investigation
and indeed that doesn't just to pick up
on something that David said that
doesn't just extend to a criminal
investigation but also extends to an
investig investigation by a state body
now the BBC is a public service
broadcaster there will be questions in
people's minds questions and lawyers
Minds about whether or not that
protection should extend through a BBC
investigation and then query what
happens if there's no findings against
this individual that could that could be
that this name is it
it carries on being below below the
radar as it were
um forever
um and that I mean that's a real
possibility isn't it that this name
never comes out never comes out the
person could end up back on television
yeah yeah with all the suspicions still
surrounding the situation and of course
um again not with this knowledge gap of
not knowing really what the allegations
were or um how the investigation went
and I think there will be some pressure
on the BBC to at least
um now that they're under this level of
scrutiny to really be seen to be and
making sure that they are and get
following through with the rest of this
investigation properly I'm probably
reporting on it in some way okay now
police have asked the BBC to pause their
investigation well police officers
conduct an assessment of what's going on
so what are the police considering
Persephone back to you what will be uh
it's a scoping exercise they're calling
it right so they're looking ahead
there's as you write so there's no
investigation nothing has been launched
but they're kind of examining what's
going on they'll be looking at the
evidence that the sun has them that
their parents have provided dead they'll
be left so will they go to the Sun
newspaper themselves and what demands
that the sun release sources that well I
think they'll go that I'm I'm not a
criminal lawyer but they're likely go to
go to the parents and go to the um go to
the alleged victim and be asking them
for more information very difficult to
have it for the police to pursue a
complaint with it with an unwilling
victim
um and they will be looking at all the
evidence that exists so we are I mean
you mentioned earlier the possibility of
um images of an underage
um child which of course raises
additional privacy concerns because
we're dealing with the rights of
children
um and again but because we just there's
this knowledge Gap in um in what we know
about the allegations we just can't
really say more about what it is exactly
that the police will be looking at but
bank statements photographs
um and and reports and statements from
the party is concerned and as the person
that sent to this says that it's all
rubbish and refused the claims you
mentioned you know a complaint from a
unwilling victim Can the police still
pursue something like that with this
with this kind of law that potential law
breaking that they're looking at yeah
the police can pursue it it's sort of
out of the victim's hands rather once a
report's been been made um but it
depends we have to make the report sorry
so
so that's been recorded
um so it will depend on what what
evidence is provided by all parties um
but if you've got an unwilling victim
whose evidence is changing or is giving
a you know a certain statement that's
going to be be taken into account by the
police as well but at this stage should
we understand that no law has been
improved we just don't know we don't
know we don't know what's actually
happened at this point all right so
plenty more to come on this Sky News
special on the BBC in crisis and coming
up after the break we will look at the
future of the organization and whether
or not this damage this reputation from
this point on return
foreign
[Music]
this is effectively a neonatal incubator
and just being able to bring into your
studio today is a pretty big thing we're
offering a way to make Healthcare
flexible within the NHS at the moment
and other countries around the world so
this is a full neonatal incubator which
I've pointed to your studio today
usually you'd probably need a crane to
get all these systems in a massive big
bulky heavy piece of equipment and tell
me what it's used for while you're while
you're putting it together for me so
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to keep a baby when they're born
preterm in something called the thermal
neutral zone and you can think of it
kind of at the temperature of the
mother's womb it means they're spending
their energy on growing rather than
trying to keep themselves warm and it's
the very base of neonatal care so if you
think of neonatal carers an upside down
triangle a thermal regulation really is
the bottom of it without it nothing else
goes well so this is a device that
really
is meant to save kids and not just let
them survive but also thrive
and you can see you know we've worked a
lot on the usability of the device so it
goes up very easily one button operation
include a battery inside of it
and you've got everything you need it's
being used in the NHS to keep babies
closer to mother and father in a very
stressful time we're saving time money
but it stays but also in countries like
Ukraine at the moment where because it's
flexible we can go down to bomb shelters
and into NICU it means they don't have
to choose between keeping babies warm on
the nurses potentially being maimed
which is a horrible state to be in but
we can offer them something that helps
originally I'm a product designer design
engineer by background we're giving the
brief the design Summit solves a problem
uh with the iwatcher documentary they
explained that because they lacked what
they thought was a simple medical device
globally so not just places where you
might think of these but parts of the
NHS us they're effectively losing entire
Generations I then tell my parents about
it and found out my mother was one of
the first babies in incubation in the UK
in the 1960s I've got pictures of it as
well so it became a personal story for
me then as well I wouldn't be here
without one of these
um we've got our manufacturer in the UK
we've got more development to do the
vision of the company is to give back a
small to healthcare access to Children
we've got lots of other products we want
to develop this is just the start this
is just our our flag in the ground
welcome back now this morning the BBC
publishes annual report including a list
of its highest paid Stars the release
was of course overshadowed by the
Scandal that the corporation is facing
but it does remind us that the
broadcaster is still publicly funded so
how can the BBC recover from this
Scandal I'm going to start with a BBC
member on the panel before I go to David
uh the BBC I mean it's going to have to
recover isn't it but how how much is
reputation going to be charged by by
this um well I mean I think the word
Scandal might be over the top in that
sense in my opinion but actually you
know I think you'd be very naive anybody
would be very naive to think that this
isn't a bad period for the BBC because
actually you're living through something
in the when you're in the head of storm
it always feels like it's worse than
what it is I think when we look at this
we get to the end whatever that end is
when we get to the end it may feel very
different now there are issues I think
obviously you know Tim Tim Davey
mentioned earlier on about you know red
flags and did we behave were we quick
enough Etc I think that will be there'll
be around there'll be a root and Branch
look at the complaints process and how
long it has taken I think that's the
right thing to do but in terms of what
has happened
this is part of the world we live in now
you know people may have portfolio
careers so then there are issues about
whether or not how much they represent
the BBC and then there are issues about
whether or not they've there's been any
illegality so I think when we get to the
end of this I think the BBC will you
know not not knowing what's going to
happen it depends on whether or not that
it it becomes bigger and bigger and so
and loads of people come out of the
woodwork and there's loads of illegality
then it will be really bad then we'll be
back in the saddle kind of territory but
if it if it's as he looks like it's
playing out right now which is not
illegal but actually the issues around
morality and whether or not whether or
not that brings a well-known face of the
BBC brings the BBC into disrepute
there'll be some short-term damage but
not the long-term damage that something
like Savile really caused a normal short
sense of it I mean the thing is when
when you mention the Sabbath and there's
been other Affairs as well of other
hyper presenters these are cumulative
aren't they in the Public's mind they
add to this idea that the BBC publicly
funded is not run as a decent
organization yeah yes it's not ideal
um I think it's like you said it just
truly depends on what the outcome of
this situation is
um I think transparency is key I felt
today
um the interview
I didn't like the fact that only BBC
were doing it like why was no other sort
of News broadcasters there you've asked
to speak to them haven't you Jason we
have asked you yeah
the annual report obviously the
questions were questions were put in by
journalists but for example the question
had to be typed yeah uh it was then
asked by a BBC person from The Press
office to the director General so if the
Dexter General didn't answer your
question you certainly couldn't come in
with a follow-up but that's control it
is good control but the result has to be
that they're more transparent in future
I mean that's a root and British perform
it just sounds like the kind of language
you hear all the time doesn't it it's
true but honestly it really is the best
policy with this and I feel the time I
just feel more transparency what
happened within those seven weeks
um why people feel it was far too slow
explain why what was going on was there
an investigation like how thorough was
the investigation I think just there's
so many answers unquestioned and I
unanswered and I feel it continued with
today as well like not many answers were
questioning uh well no not many
questions or answers sorry
um yeah I I just feel transparency is
key um I think BBC obviously they'll
crack on they'll carry on unless it is
something Monumental like Jimmy savile's
situation again but I think from a
social media perspective like I was
looking it up we put some software and
like 92 percent was negative about the
BBC across three different platforms
which is pretty striking really so
they've got a lot to work with and David
what do you what's your sense when this
plays out I mean I know I know you think
it's been overplayed anyway but talk to
us about that reputational damage as I
said it's all the cumulative impact of
these kind of bad news stories about the
organization about their high profile
Stars
look there's you can't get through this
kind of thing without suffering
collateral damage uh and although I
think Tim Davis uh done pretty well in
trying to handle matter uh we've seen
far worse outcomes uh if you remember
the uh hold Jonathan Ross uh Radio 2 uh
issue
um where the BBC's behavior in managing
its own staff has come under uh quite
severe
um attack the irony here is that one of
the reasons the PPC is so sensitive
about naming the presenter is because of
its grossly unacceptable Behavior with
regard to clear friction which ended up
costing the corporation two million
pounds in Damages and costs and where
the judge uh in the case was scathing
about the way the BBC had effectively
blackmailed South Yorkshire police into
mounting a completely pointless raid on
Cliff Richard's uh apartment uh and then
you know sticking a helicopter on the
story and putting it at the top of the
lunchtime news so nothing happened to
the BBC as without that nobody was
disciplined nobody was fired uh Tony
Hall who was then the uh director
General even said the judge didn't
understand the law I mean it's
extraordinary so uh the sensitivity here
is so ironic when they had zero
sensitivity about Cliff Richard and
where the evidence is Cliff Richard was
close to zero so my guess is that
they're being as cautious as they can be
and as capital as that can be I think
Oculus is quite right in saying that
eventually the storm will blow over uh
and the BBC will move on and that 92
negativity is short term very temperate
in six months time people will have
forgotten the whole thing existed uh let
alone what they thought about it so you
know you buckle down you take the storm
as it comes and you come out the other
side
Persephone how much do you agree with
with that do you think people will have
just moved on from this in six months I
mean of course it depends on the outcome
of this thing I almost think it doesn't
necessarily depend on the outcome but I
agree with what Lauren says is that it
depends on their transparency about how
they deal with the process and almost
regardless of the outcome what they need
to show now and they've built on that
today by releasing their timeline they
need to make sure that the public
believe that they did the right thing at
every step of the process and that
they're now being transparent about that
I mean even the fact that they brought
in those sort of processes prior to you
know those sort of the investigations
unit can't be a brand new thing that
must have been in place for a while so
the process is already there this is the
point I'm trying to to get to that it
feels like a lot of these processes
already in place you know the BBC didn't
seem quite to be able to live up to
their own their own standards that it
said we just don't know that and I think
that's the problem right excellent Jason
final thoughts from you've only got a
couple of minutes left I mean talk to us
about the BBC's reputation going forward
and you can't speak as to where this
story goes because no one knows but you
know well it's been like a tennis match
hasn't it between the BBC on the North
Bank and the sun on the south bank and
The Shard and the balls landed in the
net geographically at uh Scotland Yard
or that's what it seemed like but it
won't stay there they they will
obviously come to the conclusion of
their investigation but it may not even
stay there for that long because you've
got those tweets coming out from other
presenters like Jeremy Vine saying
something needs to happen now you've got
another story that's emerged on the BBC
other stories May emerge so whilst the
BBC might have hoped for a little bit of
time and I think the director General is
looking to the Long View he's thinking
how's my reputation going to look in a
year's time have I cut that middle
ground because right now information
maybe even within the BBC isn't all that
it needs to be for everyone to decide
which camp they're in which way they
jump so I think at the moment we're
talking about how they've managed this
crisis this crisis is not over they're
still in it yeah so we're able to do a
special show in another couple of days
yes thank you so much for that David LST
BBC producer Ander head of channel five
thank you very much for your points
Persephone Richmond Baker Carteret thank
you very much Lauren beaching appreciate
you and I said Thank you and Arco Ahmed
thank you very much for coming in all
right so I hope you answered some of
your questions on the situation at the
BBC but as Jason rightly points out we
are still right in the very midst of
this crisis so there's gonna be plenty
more to come but from us that's it so
let's take a look at what the weather
has in store for the next couple of days
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well it is warming up in southern Europe
but it'll be on the cool side here with
unsettled weather continuing there will
be showers around this evening some of
which will be heavy and thundering and
prolonged mainly in the North and the
west of the country
further showers overnight which will
move East but much of Central and
Eastern England and Eastern Scotland
look to be dry it'll be a little cooler
and fresher than recently especially in
the Southeast showers will spread to
most Parts tomorrow morning becoming
heavy and thundering in places again but
there'll be some sunshine too Northern
parts look most at risk of slow-moving
thunderstorms it'll be cool for most and
Breezy in the South especially near
Channel coasts in the afternoon will be
similar but central island will be
mainly fine while Central Britain will
turn it drier later Thursday will bring
further showers some thundery but they
should be more scattered than recently
leaving more in the way of sunshine
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
and just to remind you of course that
the situation at the BBC is shorter
feature in much of tomorrow morning's
newspapers we'll have our extended press
preview and News Review that is from 10
to 30 this evening tonight's news and
tomorrow's headlines now joining Anna
botting from 10 30 will be the
journalists and broadcasters Jenny
cleeman and Ali Mirage
and scan that QR code that you see on
your screen right now and you can listen
to the latest edition of The Sky News
Daily
in this one Kimberly is looking at the
crisis at the BBC you can subscribe for
free wherever you find your podcasts and
on the Sky News app too
now you're watching Sky News tonight and
coming up in the next down a second
complaint has been made against an
unnamed BBC presenter will have the
latest Army crisis at the BBC at the top
of the hour stay with us
foreign